bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la chaîne
de vulgarisation des instances
politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en 5 10
minutes et détail des organismes
politiques en france
aujourd'hui on va parler du gouvernement
si on regarde l'article 20 de la
constitution
on peut lire que le gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation
il dispose de l'administration et de la
force armée
il est responsable devant le parlement
dans les conditions et suivant les
procédures prévues aux articles 49 et 50
tout ça veut dire que c'est le
gouvernement qui choisit la politique du
pays dès qu'il applique que toutes les
administrations de france peuvent agir
suivant les choix du gouvernement et
qu'il assure la mise en oeuvre des choix
militaire de l'êta on voit aussi que le
gouvernement est responsable devant le
parlement
ça veut dire que les députés peuvent
déposer une motion de censure
s'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec la
déclaration de politique générale du
premier ministre ou s'ils sont contre
l'utilisation d'un 49 3 dans ce cas là
le gouvernement doit démissionner le
parlement possède aussi d'autres outils
de contrôle du gouvernement
les commission denquête les questions
orales ou écrites ou des auditions des
membres du gouvernement par exemple
dans le détail le gouvernement c'est le
premier ministre les ministres d'état
des sortes de super ministre capable
d'organiser des réunions
interministérielles
les ministres les ministres délégués qui
travaillent pour les ministres les
secrétaires d'état ils sont un peu comme
les ministres délégués
d'ailleurs certains gouvernements ont
des ministres délégués d'autres pays
secrétaire d'état et pour la première
fois sous la vème république
dans le gouvernement fillon de 2007 on a
pu voir la nomination d'un haut
commissaire est donc tout ça certains le
gouvernement les médias parlent aussi
souvent du gouvernement pour parler par
exemple du président la république du
parlement ou du conseil constitutionnel
alors qu'ils ne font pas partie du
gouvernement même s'il participe aussi à
la gestion de l'état
tous les mercredis a lieu le conseil des
ministres c'est la réunion de tous les
ministres et du président de la
république au palais des visées pendant
ces réunions il crée les projets de loi
pour rappel les projets de lois sont les
lois proposées par le gouvernement alors
que les propositions de loi sont celles
proposées par les parlementaires
ils font aussi les décrets d'application
pour les lois déjà votées par le
parlement et certaines mesures
réglementaires on dit que le
gouvernement est une institution du
pouvoir exécutif
l'un des trois pouvoirs constituants un
état avec le pouvoir législatif et le
pouvoir judiciaire
pour rappel le pouvoir exécutif s'est
dirigé la police exécuter les lois
représenter l'état auprès des
juridictions diriger la force militaire
dirigé l'administration et les services
publics diriger la diplomatie les
négocier les traités nommer les
fonctionnaires et édicter des règlements
mais le gouvernement n'est pas seul en
effet le pouvoir exécutif en france
élite bicéphale
car il est partagé entre le gouvernement
et le président de la république alors
que le gouvernement s'occupe plutôt des
politiques économiques des conflits
sociaux et du fonctionnement des
services publics
le président lui s'occupe de la france à
l'international des grands choix de
défense et des choix essentiels sur
l'avenir de l'état concernant le premier
ministre il est nommé par le président
de la république et le chef du
gouvernement
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui propose la
nomination des ministres au président et
même si c'est le chef du gouvernement
ce n'est pas le supérieur hiérarchique
des ministres en fait il dirige l'action
et la coordination du gouvernement donc
des ministres mais ne peut pas par
exemple forcer un ministre à faire
quelque chose qui ne veut pas ou même
provoquer ou nommer un ministre pour
nommer ou révoquer un ministre le
premier ministre doit obligatoirement
demander au président de la république
de le faire le premier ministre assure
l'exécution des lois et exerce le
pouvoir réglementaire sur réserve de
l'accord du président
et il est aussi responsable de la
défense nationale même si les grandes
orientations sont fixés par le président
la république qui est le chef de l'armée
les ministres eux sont nommés par le
président la république à la tête d'un
ministère y ont globalement de ranchs la
première et administratives ils sont les
supérieurs hiérarchiques d'un ministère
il ya sur sa direction
la deuxième tâche et politique ils
doivent mettre en oeuvre la politique
gouvernementale
à travers leur ministère et discuter sur
l'activité du gouvernement au parlement
et au conseil des ministres
un ministre ne peut pas être aussi
parlementaires mais il peut parler au
parlement
quand ils le souhaitent le nombre de
ministères est variable selon les
besoins et les gouvernements la plupart
du temps on retrouve quand même les
mêmes ministères comme par exemple le
ministère des affaires étrangères si
vous voulez partir à l'étranger passer
faire un tour sur leur site
il y à tous les conseils de sécurité
pour bien préparer son voyage le
ministère de la défense le ministère de
l'intérieur le ministère de la culture
et de la communication
le ministère de l'économie et des
finances le ministère de l'éducation et
de l'enseignement supérieur
le ministère de l'agriculture le
ministère des affaires sociales et de la
santé le ministère de la justice qui
s'occupe de la justice et dont le
ministre est appelé le garde des sceaux
seul le ministre de la justice est
prévue dans la constitution comme vice
président du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
voilà c'est fini pour cette vidéo
j'espère que vous aura plu et que vous
n'aurez appris un peu plus sur le
gouvernement
si vous voulez en savoir encore plus
n'hésitez pas à aller voir directement à
la source sur les sites officiels du
gouvernement et le site vie publique
vous pouvez désormais nous suivre sur
twitter et facebook
les liens sont dans la description
n'hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire
et à très bientôt